retour à l'aube de la pandémie quand
lakovic 19 était perçu comme une menace
lointaine début 2020 la santé publique
canadienne se voulaient rassurantes les
restes prouvera la canada au canada pour
la propagation est très faible
un an plus tard l'heure est au bilan ils
sont accablants
nous avons constaté que le gouvernement
n'était pas aussi près qu'il aurait pu
l'être
l' agence de la santé publique du canada
a sous-estimé les risques
elle était mal outillé pour affronter la
pandémie conclut la vérificatrice
générale technologies désuètes
traitement manuel des données lacunes
dans le partage d'information de santé
avec les provinces et des territoires
les plans d'urgence était dépassé et
n'avait pas été testée les leçons de la
crise du h1n1
une décennie plus tôt n'ont pas servi je
suis découragé quelle agence n'a pas
dressé des lacunes de longue date
autre constat d'échec la surveillance
des voyageurs qui rentraient au pays
pour les deux tiers des personnes
arrivées en mai et juin derniers lagence
ne sais même pas si la quarantaine
obligatoire a été respectée les
voyageurs jugés à risque de violer les
règles n'ont pas été signalées
systématiquement aux forces de l'ordre
des révélations qui ont rebondi aux
communes le gouvernement réaliste il
qu'il est responsable de grossière
négligence pourquoi ce gouvernement
at-il éliminer les capacités d'un lot
avant le pain de mie de la coved 19000
employés ont été ajoutées à l' agence de
la santé publique
un coup de barre a été donnée un sur la
ministre de la santé la vérificatrice
générale espère que les lacunes seront
corrigés pour demain c'est rare quand
même valeur sur la bonne préparation
mais il faut être bien préparé pour une
crise jusqu'où ira le canada pour
améliorer ses pratiques d'autres pays
ont décidé d'opérer des changements en
profondeur royaume uni par exemple une
nouvelle agence sera mis sur pied et
basse concentré spécifiquement sur le
contrôle des maladies infectieuses ici
louis blouin radio canada